they were gone in an instant a
five-year-old girl and two teenagers
among the dead Leona Harper was 14 years
old her parents told local radio she
would be sorely missed balloon was a
little gem
Freya gone
uh very friendly
it's a lovely person
um
very quiet laid back
um
love life
I don't personally know who's a Duggar
driver
um
a massive thank you to him
because he just didn't stop until he got
her
24 hours before we got her yeah and she
she was last taken out
the search team worked through the night
following the suspected gas explosion at
this petrol station they refused to give
up until every person reported missing
had been accounted for
Brendan McGinley was among those who
rushed to the scene I'm lucky
I was saying to
Colin who was one of the first gays on
the scene his lasting memories terrible
um the first fella that he tried to
rescue died in his arms
but my memory is better because my
memory is taking a little gear load
we're asking a little earload which is
and she's okay
that's my
take home
that's what I'll hang on to
the blast largely demolished the
building people who'd been in apartments
above were trapped with those in the
shop below the investigation will take
some time but this place will never be
the same again
this tiny Community has come to the
world's attention for all the wrong
reasons but they've been comforted by a
message of condolence from Pope Francis
and another from King Charles who said
he and the queen consort were filled
with immense sadness when they heard
about the tragedy
for a village of 400 residents it's
difficult to process the scale of their
loss they're already preparing for a
series of funerals and will bury their
dead this week
David Blevins Sky News at Chrysler in
County Donegal